so you're one of the reigning Queens of
Hallmark everybody you know the last
time I was here you told us we were like
The Avengers it's on the adventures of
Hallmark I'm down for The Avengers The
Avengers you three yo yo all in all the
movies because I've always seen them
because my sister my mom we're our whole
family everybody loves them tell us
about your latest what's this one okay
so magical Christmas Village is so fun
because first of all it starts with like
the story of Marlo Thomas plays my mom
in this movie which is amazing I'm I
know amazing but um you know so there's
the real family Dynamic of her and I
having to live together right before the
holidays so it's already like a
stressful time of year yeah but she's
coming to live with me and we are not
people who are meant to be living
together
um uh so it's a great comedy I know it's
so great and she's the queen of Comedy
so that was amazing
um and so that part's really like
realistic and then she brings with her
this family Christmas Village have you
ever seen those like amazing Villages
that people put in their homes do you
have one I have like a metropolis yeah
yeah oh my God I'm like that crazy I
love all the Charles Dickens like all
all of it this movie is for you okay so
so then but because the little girl my
character's daughter makes a wish when
she's putting together the Christmas
Village yeah it maybe has a little magic
where it's helping like she plays with
the figurines I love when magic is
involved I do too yes especially
Christmas magic yeah yeah so then we
created these characters from my
character Summer She's you know she's
got her life together she's a single mom
she's got you know all her ducks in a
row and so she needed a little magic to
like get her off her game to meet up
with this guy she would never have
normally met yeah you know so the
Christmas Village sort of brings them
together and it's Luke right I just had
Luke's on here yeah yes he told me that
he was just I love him he's so nice such
a nice guy yeah funny and super like his
wit I was like well that was under the
radar yeah he's really really funny but
he's also super romantic he's so great
in this movie he was really funny he
loves country music of course he's
romantic yeah he was like I love me some
Garth Brooks I'm like I'm sorry what I
was like that's awesome wait you
produced this movie and you have more in
store with homework right did you do
like a deal I heard I do have a deal
with Hallmark they um are so wonderful
to work with super supportive everybody
that works with them says they love
their lives yeah yeah yeah because
they're just really supportive of like
telling these female stories you know
helping I I like to bring in a lot of
female directors also so and they're
real good and they do yes they're really
empowering and I love working with them
so yes I have other projects I'm working
on for um for next year which I'm really
excited to come back and tell you all
about yeah that's cool because now you
get to like find stories too that maybe
you like and you get to produce that
yeah no I I love reading stories reading
books finding IP um that I want to turn
into movies right you know it's like and
I feel like I'm the Hallmark audience
I'm that person who wants to watch these
romantic comedies they're not making
them in feature films anymore so or you
know on the movie screen so like yeah on
a Friday night yeah we're in we love
them I love rum I know
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
I'm going
[Music]